this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking a look at the low poly
massively multiplayer shooter battle bit
remastered which it's fair to say
pleasantly surprised him I just want to
say with the ejected cases on in this
game here they are barely visible flying
speed out of the gun at extreme angles
because that's how guns work this game
with its very simple Graphics is doing a
better job than a lot of mainstream AAA
games have done historically with that
particular aspect make sure to subscribe
and let us know what other games or guns
you'd like to see Jonathan break down in
the comment section down below right
let's take a look at the guns of battle
bit remastered
so my first experience of this game is
going to be a pretty detailed but
untextured take on well it says M4A1 I
don't know if that's an M4A1 assuming
that's not meant to be a suppressor on
the end and is in fact the barrel which
looks very large in diameter but not
enough to be a suppressor so it does say
Barrel so let's take it on it at its
word considering the view polygons that
go into this game because I know that
I'm ready to see that much detail like
we've got the selector switch now I've
just I've grabbed a um this is a lantac
battle Raven with a relatively short but
very heavy barrel and a little short
suppressor on the end it it has the
Magpul butt stock on it that the CTR
stock that is being replicated here so
it's the closest thing I could I could
find on the racket short notice um but
it's it's not an M4 I'm not entirely
sure that this is either but loads of
detail the selector switch the rear
takedown pin the front pivot pin the all
the angles on the receiver look good it
this could have this could afford to be
a lot less detailed I think considering
the the sort of world and character
Graphics that that we're about to see
all right this one is rather relevant to
my interests not so many depictions of
the LSW light support weapon variant of
the sa80 the l86 A1 or as I have um I've
actually picked up the wrong one this is
an l86 A2 but you know what given the
given the graphics of this game
it doesn't really matter so the only
thing that the game could represent
given its Graphics would be this cocking
handle so this is that comma shaped
cocking handle and the idea of that it
is also a case deflector 5 case
deflector so it's easier to get hold of
than the old A1 cocking handle and when
it's at the rear like that it is it's
got a sort of facing on it to help it
resist the damage of being hit
repeatedly by hot bits of sharp metal
it's helping to get that casing clear of
the of the receiver conspicuous by its
absence is the bipod
which is a permanent fixture well not
permanent it can be removed but not
meant to be user removable the bipod is
an integral part of the weapon system as
the British military calls it so it
ought not to be missing from this gun so
I'm I'm hoping that it is bitable at
some point as a sort of optional extra
but it shouldn't really be optional um
it's it's critical and integral to the
role of this weapon as a support weapon
albeit in the long run not a very
successful support weapon
thank you
another British military firearm it's
nice to see that looks very clearly in
l96 A1 gun looks great for I keep saying
because of the low quality Graphics but
you know they are consciously low
polygon they're not low quality per se
works really well the bolt handle lifts
up the Vault comes to the rear the
cartridge case comes out all the stuff
you'd expect to see just with less
detail the only quibble I was going to
have was the fact that it has what
appears to be a full power ACOG sight on
top of it which you could do with a
Picatinny adapter because the the A1 did
not have a um Picatinny Mill standard
1913 rail on it the 80 rifle had to have
a an adapter interface to take the acob
and indeed the
the modernized A3 receiver has the the
picatinny rail on there as standard but
um this generation no so you can't just
slap on an ACOG you can only install a
sousat now In fairness to the to the
British that was a NATO standard rail
it's just that only we and the Spanish I
think used it so we kind of we tried to
do the right thing and uh it didn't help
foreign
gun here the P90 fnp90 of course I can
make out the the cocking slide as it
were on the left hand side all the
various screws that hold the the
clamshell polymer receiver together you
know all basic features of the weapon of
that and as it's demonstrated we can see
the cartridge cases and even gases
effectively the exhaust gases are firing
the cartridge coming out in little paths
from the bottom of the gun which I think
if you looked hard enough you'd probably
would see on the real firearm because
that's the that's where the breach is so
you're going to get some gases exiting
that ejection Port which is on the
bottom of the weapon and we don't
normally don't look look at look at it
or for it but it is there and it has a
pivoting little cover that you can shut
to make sure no dirt gets in I did
notice on the reload there that the gun
is locking open when the magazine is
being changed and then something is
releasing the bolt forward P90 has no
hold open device guys you replace the
magazine you then have to run the
charging handle as they say to chamber
around from the magazine so I'm very
much enjoying the fact the game has
inspection animations that's really good
I don't think unlocking and lifting up
the P90 magazine is going to show you
very much this is a closed Bob weapon
the bolt is closed either on an empty
chamber or on around you can't see that
from lifting up the magazine nice touch
but not not really necessary not
particularly helpful what you need to do
with the P90 is remove the magazine
press check essentially and then
reinstall the magazine it's a downside
of the design in some ways because you
you know on another typical like an AR
you can simply check the chamber with
the magazine pull the Press check as it
were with the magazine fitted well the
P90 magazine gets in the way of that
foreign
we've now got the RPG 7 here and another
good job look you know good modeling I'm
not sure you'd want to hold the round
that way around because we'd make it
very hard to insert now as this weapon
was designed to be used you would have
an assistant who loads uh the round for
you we have although the Warhead isn't
super detailed we have got enough length
there to suggest that it has the
expelling charge screwed on the back of
it which is a something that games have
consistently failed to do and movies
actually they don't realize that there
has to be a a charge that screws on the
back of the wall head to get it 15
meters downrange before the rocket motor
kicks in remember this is a recoilless
weapon with a rocket assisted Warhead
and then the effect on target is is
fantastic better than what I've seen on
um a lot of fully featured
graphical games it might be perhaps a
bit excessive for what the RPG 7
actually does but in terms of gameplay
that having the roof blow off slightly
is just is very cool and to be fair it
hasn't blown the whole wall down or
anything it's made a it's knocked out
part of it now the effect of an actual
high explosive anti-tank shape charge
Warhead is actually quite disappointing
if you if you look this up obviously not
if you get one shot at you because it's
essentially a if it's if it's fired at
not armor then it's going to function a
bit like a large Granite hand grenade
lots of fragmentation and some blast
that's not its primary purpose though
although there is an anti-personnel
version It's meant to create that jet of
particles to penetrate steel armor so it
it has that very tiny little hole with a
sort of black smear on the outside of
the wall and then whatever damage on the
inside so in a way this is unrealistic
but I think on balance it works really
well and we have a crack rotation round
so that would be the og7 we're not
calling it that we're calling it
fragmentation the OG 7 round has because
it has no rocket motor is super short
and does not stick out massively from
the front of the the launcher like
basically all of the other rounds do
this is sticking out quite far and it's
shaped like a sort of miniature missile
so it doesn't doesn't look like the
standard Soviet type frag round
anti-personnel round but maybe it's
another another one or based on on
another one but the fact that it's even
in the game like how many mainstream
Shooters let you use different Warheads
on your rpg7 virtually none of them
foreign
Go full Magnum I guess it should be
pronounced Asha 12 or sh as in papasha
I'd better check that for the future but
um 12.7 50 caliber uh revolver firing
the same ammunition as that insane
um Ash or Asher 12 rifle thing that we
know from the current generation of Call
Of Duty Modern Warfare which is a real
Russian design as is this and as we saw
from the external view firing the barrel
is at the bottom a bit like a Metabo or
something in order presumably to help
tame the significant recoil of this
really powerful revolver I can't quite
tell what's operating on this Hammer
cylinder but that obviously the cylinder
swings out and is reloaded with a speed
loader it is kicking out cases somehow
which is not possible so maybe that's an
engine limitation in some way that the
way it's set up guns have to have to
eject cartridge cases obviously the
number of revolver revolvers that are
Jack cartridge cases well very few um
for obvious reasons it's not usually
worth doing mechanically difficult to
pull off so that's just a that's
essentially a glitch but it's it's
probably a baked in glitch for now until
they can code that out
foreign
can't go wrong with it roughly uh I
guess it's an A3 uh or close enough in
the game anyway now if I've got this MP5
in Half-Life one I'd have been very
happy because it's really very detailed
but yeah by the standards of that game
certainly but yeah really good really
really well modeled you can't have an
MP5 without the HK slap not in my book
and uh there's a very blocky rendition
of it here I'm gonna say it's like the
Neo style closed fist slap but it seemed
quite gentle I think maybe it could be a
little bit more assertive in reality you
can of course do it that way just slip
it out of the notch with your thumb and
let it travel forward and it's going to
travel the same distance as if you hit
the thing but the HK manual as I respond
to pointing out does say to slap it I
suppose if I have any criticism of the
the MP5 in the game it would be I have
seen the traditional polymer 4 end with
I think a rail on the bottom and I might
have seen the odd section sort of jury
rigged to one or one side or the other
for attaching a light or something I
don't remember seeing a Tri-Rail version
of this where you have a rail on the
bottom and a rail either side as we see
in the game I'm sure someone's done it
but in any case it's not my preference
but I get that we need to be able to
accessorize I suppose if you're going to
do that though just go with a railed
handguard like the um the MP5 as it
comes from HK now has a railed handguard
fitted and a rail claw mount adapter on
the top as well so I'm purist about
these things but that's because I don't
have to use them practically so that's
probably the way I would go rather than
try to keep the classic silhouette but
still have representations of rails on
there
write some variety in the reloads here
which is interesting obviously it
applies across the game but I'm
currently looking at the AK-74 retaining
magazines clearly important if with
realistic ammunition management but
there seems to be a separate button for
an emergency reload where you dump the
magazine and just put on a fresh one I
presume you can't pick it back up either
so sacrificing however many rounds
you've had left for the sake of a faster
reload that kind of gun based gameplay I
think is fascinating and based in
reality you know operating the charging
handle at one point underhand or close
to don't really have hands in this game
and then another reload I saw there was
done with taking the right hand off
pistol grip which was the traditional
way to do it even in the era of the
AK-74 by the way the Soviet manual for
the for the AK-74 still has you doing
everything with the right hand
recognizably in AK-74 in terms of the
curvature of the magazine the muzzle
brake on the end of the barrel and even
a couple of Minor Details of the shape
of the thing the I guess a slight
downside out of the the way these models
are done is that the top cover doesn't
appear to be a separate piece which it
probably could be at the level of detail
that the game operates at but we do have
the push button for the for the top
cover removal the little Tang for the
attachment of the butt stock now I will
say um I've been fortunate enough to to
shoot an AK-74 once or twice The Recoil
is minimal that muzzle break is
incredibly effective the cartridges is
low recoil inherently as well and so I
think this has too much recoil in
particular in automatic fire bursts of
fire whatever you want to call it where
that cumulative effect starts to bring
up the muzzle that just doesn't happen
with the 74 as long as you're pulling it
in with any degree of skill as I have
proven
um it just stays on if you have to fire
automatic fire from the shoulder with a
rifle which is very much not not the
fashion these days then an AK-74 is
right up there for one of the best
options
okay
right couple of things
clearly these weapons are even more
customizable than I thought they were
because we've got uh what appears to be
a middle finger front sight and uh just
just fingers and hands and I I haven't
even seen someone do that on a real
firearm that's special
I I hope that the game overall maintains
the sort of serious tone with the sit
with sort of cutesy Graphics because
that works well um too much of this kind
of thing might take me out of it but
that was funny now also in the same as
I'm trying I'm trying very hard to focus
on an on-screen indicator that says
combining magazines that I don't think
I've seen before so we've got realistic
ammunition management we might have one
round in one magazine five in another
you can combine pretty desperate if you
did this but you can combine the one
round magazine into the five round
magazine and get one magazine of six
rounds which is going to give you ever
so slight Edge in an encounter can you
do it this quickly obviously not you'd
have to take cover but you're pretty
assured you're not going to get overrun
and shot um and then look at removing
rounds from magazines stowing them or
throwing them away and inserting them
into your other magazines it would be a
much longer more involved process but
very interesting that it's in the game
I'm kind of astonished and mechanic I've
never seen before is debuting for me
anyway in this particular game again not
to disparage the game
sniper rifle M200 I'm sure you'll
recognize if not the name then the
design of the rifle it's the shytac M200
or M200 intervention one that we don't
have in the collection regrettably but
very distinctive and popped up quite a
few times in various popular culture
settings what's interesting about it for
me though is the rangefinder that's been
implemented so it's there's a there's a
physical Rangefinder device on the side
of the the gun with a readout and what I
think you must have to do is sort of
scope what you want to do then you have
to unaim down sights as it were look at
the readouts of where your reticle
currently is to get the range then go
back into the scope and then hold over
by well I guess you would learn by trial
and error what the whole logo would be I
very much doubt you can do it from any
kind of data but I love the idea there
might be someone somewhere with actual
data cards or sheets for their Minecraft
sniper rifle
yeah
foreign
I was just thinking that given the lower
powered Graphics engine here that we
could push out our sniping in this game
to realistic distances because there's
far too much bullet drop in Battlefield
and that's to do with the size of the
levels as well as graphics and all of
that and I've seen a load of kills done
in this footage 200 meters for 300
meters maybe 400 and I just now saw an
842 meter long distance kill come up
which is astonishing I don't I've never
seen in any game I've played kills out
to that long range now that's that's
still nowhere near what a rifle like
this is capable of and in the right
hands on the right day but it's way more
than I've seen a video game do so that's
that's really impressive stuff
just as a measure of how impressed I am
with this with this game I accidentally
skipped past the preview of the weapon
and what I got at the next gun was the
iron sight View and I instantly
recognized as the FN FAL just from that
view with these graphics and that's I
think that shows you how effective and
how well done they are and it's a really
nicely done FAL somewhat modernized it's
got rails on it I guess if you're going
to use an FAL in Modern Combat you would
want that the top cover is in this
version of the gun anyway
um it appears to be a separate piece in
a different color I'd like to see that
on the okay maybe there's more
differentiation here in terms of color
and component parts maybe this one's
been modeled more recently I don't know
selective selective fire I haven't
mentioned but all you know all the guns
that should have it seem to have it
flick from semi-automatic which is what
the fal is best at click and you're on
automatic which seems to work okay and I
think that difficulty in controlling
automatic fire is translated over to
this game as well because we're
definitely getting more muzzle rides
with firing an automatic we've got the
correct rocking magazine reload even
though it's you know it's glossing over
some of the stages because it has to
could easily just be magazine magically
attaches to gun out of thin air but no
we actually see it get rocked in so
there are there are hints of everything
that you would expect to see
foreign
the squad automatic weapon the FN mini
me um it I could actually identify this
as a 249 if I didn't know that's what it
was supposed to be because it has the
heat shield handguard on top of it a bit
of an odd Quirk is that the bipod looks
kind of tiny and is mounted too far back
under the handguard which is really a
bit weird but easily fixed I'm sure and
then as I'm watching the thing fire
really nice job with the belt of
ammunition in the first place but when
it runs out we still have empty links on
the left side of the gun coming out of
the belt box if that all ammunition's
gone through the gun all the links
should be separated and on the floor by
now there should be no belt on the left
side at all but instead it's somehow
like I guess the the belt model is
persistent the rounds have all been
fired so there's there's a kind of a
glitch there or an oversight maybe I
just want to say with the ejected cases
on in this game something I've been
pointing out for a bit recently it feels
like is that we don't have that
perpendicular perfect procession didn't
mean to alliterate like that of cases
coming out of the of the gun which is in
so many games here they are barely
visible flying speed out of the gun at
extreme angles because that's how guns
work they you know the the physics of
the whole thing spins them out of the
gun and they go at some speed so this
yet again this game with its very simple
Graphics is doing a better job than a
lot of mainstream AAA games have done
historically with that particular aspect
thanks for joining us guys for The Guns
of battle bit which is a new game to me
absolutely fascinating cool to see what
they've done with very limited resources
essentially if you'd like to see more of
our collection here at the Royal
armories we have our own channel also
here on YouTube and various social media
channels as well if you'd like to check
those out and free museums so there's
lots to lots to see if you'd like to
engage with with us here at the Royal
armories regardless of that we'll see
you again here on this channel next week